In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion from May 31st, on which we commemorate the Holy Martyr
Hermias.
On the 31st of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy Martyr Hermias and of the Megas
who having been converted, perished by the sword.
The Holy and Glorious Martyr Hermias was an elderly soldier who had spent long years in the
Roman army at Comana in Pontus.
Completing his service in the reign of Antonio's Pius, he refused any retirement pay and confessed
his faith in Christ our God.
He was immediately arrested and denounced before Sebastian the governor, who summoned him
to sacrifice to the false gods in order to demonstrate his loyalty to the Emperor.
When Hermias energetically refused, he was put to torture.
The executioners first broke his jaw and then tore the flesh from his face.
He was then thrown into a burning furnace from which he emerged unhurt to the stupification
of all.
Sebastian decided to have recourse to a Megas who prepared a virulent poison to use on
the saint, but as soon as he saw that it did Hermias know harm, he confessed in his turn
the divine power of Christ and was immediately beheaded.
Hermias was then put to further torture.
He was plunged into boiling water.
His eyes were gouged out and then they hanged him head downwards for three days.
Finally, the soldier of Christ, having emerged victorious from all these trials, was beheaded
and thus received the victor's wreath in heaven.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.